[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm link and
I'm Rhett this week at the round table
of dim lighting we're going to be
answering your questions about parenting
because or just parents kids the
relationships going both way it could be
things that apply to kids things that
apply to parents because we've been both
kids and parents and we still are rhett
newsflash and again as we as we have
gotten in the habit of saying when we
answer your questions
we're not qualified to give advice take
our advice at your own risk
we do not we have engineering degrees
which taught us nothing about child
psychology school what about the school
of hard knocks man we've we haven't even
been through that
just be real exactly we just have
children who are relatively
well-adjusted I mean I I wouldn't say
particularly well-adjusted I would say
well they're bleah well they're
well-loved they're very loved and I and
I would think that they're this moment
everything's okay you know anything I
could go right and find out that they've
broken a law we are potentially
temporary success stories as parents so
all that to say just you know take our
advice with a grain of salt if you're
coming to us to actually learn how to be
a parent you've got bigger problems I
don't think your buddies coming to us
that way I don't think you should go to
anybody for four complete answers I'm
gonna step out on that limb I think
every you know and that's one of the
things I try to teach my kids is that
like don't just be a blind follower of
any one person you know it's like you
got it as a cult you know you can't do
that definitely don't do that with us
even though we're two people or two
people so it's okay you can blindly
follow us you want to say yeah yeah so
let's get let's get into some questions
so let's jump right into the first one I
ate a cookie my stomach hurts a little
bit well you know me running out as you
told me that we had some cookies
somebody gifted us some cookies yeah and
I saw you in the cookie and I was like I
gotta get one of them
that's the only way I'm gonna be able to
get to this podcast and then then you
started call you saying man that's what
I was thinking and when he said was
where'd you get that cookie yeah I've -
subtext man and then you said I feel a
little sick cuz they're not cooking I'm
like well I guess I'm not gonna get a
cookie so here I am cookie las' jumped a
man with a with a with a jar of water
this is how you expect me to make it
through this you have a cookie oh it's
not my role to sustain you
uh yeah Here I am cookie full and I'm
complaining about it I'm kind of
miserable I'm just hungry you should be
grateful
Kevin Urban hey fellas when my wife was
pregnant with our first we made a bet on
the gender whoever won got ten I'm not
changing that diapers ten vetoes I guess
boy and one during the entirety of no no
no I don't think you rather whoever won
the got ten I'm not changing that diaper
vetoes not diapers you get ten instances
of not changing a diaper
even though it's wet I enjoyed that
that's what he meant and that's exactly
what I read I read what he wrote diapers
yeah cuz he said whomever okay are you
changing that diapers we're supposed to
resolve issues not create that well I'm
not creating the issue Jen veto it
wasn't what you said didn't make sense
blame Kevin cuz that's how he wrote it I
guess boy and one during the entirety of
my son's time in diapers I only use one
veto now we have a second son didn't
read this time I feel I have nine vetoes
left she says they expired when her
firstborn was potty-trained who's right
she's right Kevin you know why mm-hmm
because because she's always right yeah
that's true but secondarily why didn't
you use your vetoes when you had the
chance
I mean look and here's the answer cuz it
was the first child and you were trying
to gain some brownie points and your I
guarantee you that you've held this over
your wife's head you know I haven't used
all my vetoes there were very brownie
points I I've changed every time that is
the occasion
come along for me to change the diaper
I've done it I'm just calling you out
Kevin I think that you've gotten all the
mileage out of not using the vetoes and
in is in terms of brownie points
so you've used them in a different way
by not using them I'm an agreement with
Lync for a different reason and that is
the bet was about the first child the
bet expired when you had another I'm
kind of angry at you for not just using
the vetoes I'm just reading into it that
again you were trying to gain credit
just reap the reward or don't you didn't
you can learn to love changing diapers
make a game of it boy I don't know what
the rules are and how you get points but
I don't remember the last diaper I
changed but I should have bronzed the
thing you know it's like third child I
mean how many diapers did I go through
more than you unless your two kids
pooped at a rate that led to more
diapers wouldn't you like to know that
sometimes do you ever like a counter I
think about life in that way sometimes
like a an interesting reddit thread is
that data is beautiful so I mean that
one and it's one of the ones I don't
like numbers is one of the ones I sub to
and basically as people who take
different you know anything in life that
can be data eyes which is basically
anything and can be represented as a
data set and then they present it in a
beautiful way like a way cuz you because
it can be very beautiful in the way that
you present it like a chart like a but a
really beautiful chart okay and
sometimes it's just amazing data that's
not beautiful but it is beautiful not
visually you know I'm saying anyway but
it I wish sometimes if I could have a
superpower besides flying or being
invisible or teleporting the fourth one
would be to be able to create a data set
of anything that anybody brought up
because wouldn't it be interesting and
be like like an instance you would say
well linked with three kids you've
changed this Minnie Dino but I would
want to know specifically like how many
craps Lando took versus how many craps
Shepard took and it would be like
mind-blowing because it would be like
hold up Shepard took twice as many crabs
as Lando what is that
mean is he still taking more craps and
we'd be able to snap our fingers and
like what's the average amount of crap
that comes out of your youngest son
versus my youngest no we could talk
about it there weren't apps grandpap's
but I bet there's a crap app now for I
mean to to log your but I don't want to
have to log it I want to be able to
access it I was a superpower well you
can probably get averages but that's the
closest we're gonna get oh well I don't
know but we answer Kevin's question he's
wrong she's right get with the program
Kevin gee I wish I would have bronzed
the last diaper because that was one of
the one of the big milestones in
parenting is when you no longer have to
buy change or dispose of diapers but you
know what as with many things in life
the most important moments are glossed
over and you don't even know they've
happened that's sad man yeah I don't
remember it either yeah and I did change
not as many or nearly as many as my wife
did but I do not remember the last one
and let me tell you I would he use those
vetoes in the first week Michelle Scott
max asks is it okay to use the steering
wheel volume controls in order to drown
out the ramblings of a six-year-old girl
and tell her it isn't me the car just
really likes this song okay so she
doesn't see her mom she does yeah
reaching over and turning the volume up
I can't hear you and then read this next
question because I think it's very it's
very related I think that we can answer
these two questions together okay
read this question from Deirdre oh you
want me to read it yeah I don't want to
read the whole time look at me over here
reading everything okay I'm so sorry
cookie listen man making me I don't get
cookies I got to read everything I'll go
get you a good stuff around and I'll
read this question while doing it oh you
won't you know want to hear it I'll be
in there getting a cookie so choose I
just read the question Wow I got you why
do parents lie about weird things like
if you're driving at night and you turn
on the lights in the vehicle you can get
arrested or swallowing gum will make
your stomach clog up and you will die or
sleeping with wet hair will make you
sick or cracking your knuckles leads to
arthritis this is an entry fee like
these are I feel like the questions that
Deirdre are the lies that Deirdre has
pointed out these are just
misconceptions misconceptions or
misleading old wives tales but but I
think that this first question from
Michelle this it isn't me the car just
really likes this song this is a
category that's the best just to lie in
that is a lot this is basically what my
entire parenting philosophy has been
built on for years
is lying to my children you know this
I've talked about it many times okay
it's not really my philosophy but I love
screwing around with my kids I love
basically making them think things and
but fit fibbing to get a reaction yeah
but you do tell them yeah
well or do you almost always there's a
few rare exceptions where I've let
something slide for a long time because
it was funny but it's always
inconsequential and if I ever think that
there it could be consequential then I
clear it up on the spot
the most recent example of this was we
were riding along did you notice there
on the the main road that kind of
connects our homes that they were doing
the the fumigation of the apartment
buildings and so they had covered up the
whole building with a striped stuff we
pulled it we were pulled up and it was
in the distance we didn't drive past it
and Lincoln was like look it's the
circus
well that's person you kind of stepping
all over my lie but this exhaust it's a
way so we what we went we went was funny
because your kid told himself a lie and
believed it well he just saw it
it looked like a big top yeah well so we
drove by and I told Shepherd I said
Shepherd did you did you hear there's a
new circus building there's a new circus
building in town and that's it and like
he looked his eyes lit up for a second
and he looked at he was like dad I'm not
stupid but he did look at it he was
there but see I wanted my kid to think
that a fumigated house or fumigated
apartment complex was the circus come
into town and when Lincoln said look
it's the circus I was just like no
that's a so it was a complete opposite
conversation yeah they can deceived
himself and you cleared it up i deceived
my own son and then he cleared it up
himself but teach a man to fish or give
him a fish I think is the situation but
I did this to lock all the
I mean Shepherd had the advantage of
observing me say all this stuff array
and so now they're just like mom is that
true if it's Jesse's there its mom is
that true doesn't matter what I say no
mom it's worth it man he's worth it all
the memories are gonna have of all the
things the lies that I've told him I
[Laughter]
mean I do that sometimes too I I do get
a kick out of it but I don't have the I
don't have the cutthroat instinct that
you have to pull one over on my kids but
I will say that I also spend quite a bit
of time just telling them things that
are true like if we like I mean I mix in
some things that are really confusing
but I like if we're going on a hike or
whatever we like talk about the rocks
and history of the earth and all this
stuff I love doing doing that kind of
thing but I think a lot of times it can
be become a little bit like dads the
school teacher and we're on a field trip
and so I try to keep that to a minimum
yeah but so Michelle I think it's
totally okay and Deirdre the reason we
lie about weird things is because it's
fun and you got to do something to
survive this parenting thing by the way
it's a it's I would have loved to have
seen a time-lapse of then wrapped that
apartment this is not a house this thing
is like five stories tall it's like a
whole apartment complex coated in a
circus tent for fumigation also love the
fact that they made amazing they made it
look so fun with all the colors and
there's these insects just dying inside
well yeah they made that choice I wonder
why they made that choice I think it cuz
it's fun to kill insect well I think
they're repurposing circus tents I mean
it they've had a lot of circus tent
material and the circus isn't popular
anymore
well I think it I doubt that well then
what's the reason I think it's because
somebody was like it was one point so he
was like we got to wrap this whole house
we're doing kind of a I mean if you
really think about it it's a little bit
morbid like if a person's in there
they're definitely dying and if it
insects in there they're definitely
dying let's spruce it up a little bit
let's make it seem fun I mean mark all
the marketing people do the size it's
putting icing on it or we're talking
about it right now
you want to wrap your house up and you
probably don't even have a bug problem
but you're
saying that Michelle is is just it's not
a big deal that she does that I mean
basically I I just feel for I don't
think it's I don't think it's the best
thing to do but parenting a lot of times
is just desperation and survival yeah
exactly you know you do what you gotta
do yeah I'm a huge proponent of truth
but I also like to tell a little fib
here and there okay turn it on the
lights in the vehicle I don't I never
told my kids I could get you arrested
but I do tell them to turn off because
it it can lead to a crash right it's not
smart so I give them the real reason
whenever possible so I okay I don't I
don't make up the wives tales now we've
got a lot more questions to go but we
are going to take a short break
and let you know about these shirts that
link has on you can't get the one that
I'm wearing because I'm just wearing one
that I bought on the internet somewhere
else other than mythical dot store not
an advertisement for this shirt well I
may be talking about it talk about your
shirt link you ever seen this show
friends yeah yeah it's big big hit back
in the day what's it has the theme song
go I'll be there for ya just get the
shirt a mythical dot star I'll be there
so if you're if you're a fan of this
shirt or what it represents if you don't
know what it represents you just like
the shirt just buy it if you do know
what it represents what it's a homage to
then also buy it we've gotten a lots of
other good shirts over there yeah we've
gotten some feedback from a few of you
guys that love to give us feedback on
things people have have commented on
some of the shirts that we're releasing
that are obvious parodies of existing
things and I think they've said things
like guys why are you doing this that's
not very original
well because it's a parody I mean that's
a that is a fun that is a fun thing to
do is to take a very established thing
and to mythical eyes it as just an
exercise and fun but there's other
shirts that it's like lying to your kids
guys come on get with the program buy
the t-shirt mythical dot store thank you
for supporting internat Ament all right
we're back with an
the question from Kaitlin Cunningham
kids do tons of art projects during
their time in school what do you do with
all of them how many of them end up in
the trash
this is my rule if it's flat keep it if
it's 3d Chuck it hmm space saver I stack
a bunch of flatness to but I take a
picture of the 3d stuff which you make
the 3d stuff flat interesting without
crushing it and not crushing the hearts
of your children cuz it goes into the
cloud which we've talked about in a
rabbit hole episode but you do take a
video of it that goes a 360 around it
because if you did that you could one
day re-engineer it Lando is very nerdy
Lando is very artistically inclined you
know every time there's trash like
cardboard
specifically he'll he wants to keep all
of that and he always sees something in
it and he's making something so I always
want to encourage that but I'm very
clear with him that you know after you
make it with 48 hours later it's it's
it's gone you know and I also think
that's helpful because it's not like oh
this is this has got to be perfect this
has got to be here forever
it's just like you know I'm painting on
this canvas and what many of the many of
the Great's would paint over their own
thing 3 or 40 of the Great's you know
because there's always another one they
didn't even artistic genius people gonna
be and people gonna be going through
recycling decades from now and finding
Lando's creations I don't think that's
how recycling works but if it's flat I
stack somewhere that's a good system we
McLaughlin's or we don't have a lot of
systems so it's kind of like some things
are kept some things were thrown away
there's a couple of times where jesse
now kind of look at each other and get
you kind of give each other a guilty
look and you just throw it in the trash
there's no real consistency you're just
hoping that the kid doesn't know right
but I will say also shove it in the
trash then seal it in my and my kids are
not they're not prone to be attached to
things that like that everyone smile
Shepard oh [ __ ] Locke wasn't like this
at all but Shepard it'll create
something and he's kind of attached to
it but well I don't deal with that
very much when you're constantly lied to
your tend to be a free spirit exactly
now the thing that the really
interesting thing that happened very
recently is a science project
I don't know how loss happened in your
house I don't know how Locke got through
without having to do I guess it was
because it was home-schooled through all
this that's probably what happened and I
think they did do a science project at
some point somehow being a home schooler
involved is in and of itself a science a
science project yeah the results are
still out what is what is the TBD now
but so Shepherds in third grade and they
had the option of doing a science
project in four summers or what you
didn't I don't know it was optional you
could I think it was if you did the
science project you didn't have to do
homework for the month or so like that
oh you better you better jump on that
ship but Shepherd exercised his option
to do a science project on him and I but
it was a group project with two other
kids and so he's like dad I'm doing a
science project I'm like well what is it
he says tornadoes so it's like a cuz
what what is the experiment he said
making tornadoes can he do it and so you
know hypothesis I can to make it tornado
well exhibit so one of the other kids
dad's kind of helped them a we all kind
of had different roles now I'll tell you
what my role was in a second and where I
failed as a father but one of the dads
was in charge of coming up with what the
experiments were going to be and it
basically was one of these things you
know when you take like a bottle like a
plastic bottle bottle for some reason we
did one liter bottles but you can do it
with two liters and you basically fix
them together and put like a little
washer in the middle and then you fill
it with liquids and you kind of start a
tornado and then it creates this amazing
looking tornado that didn't go empties
itself until the other thing and you
turn it over and keep doing it well this
experiment was the question that was
being explored was does adding different
things to the water change the
characteristics of a tornado okay so
they added glue other dad came up with
that yeah yeah he did the hard part
they added glitter to the
water they added oil to the water and
they added sugar to the water basically
created a simple syrup by you know
boiling the sugar into the water and
then of course there was a regular water
now for some reason this dad made it
through three of the bottles he created
three of the bottles and then Jesse
comes home she says when we get back
actually the night we got back from Palm
Spring she says when we get back from
Palm Springs you've got to do the
experiments with Shepherd so you've got
to time him doing all that you've got to
do the experiment and log the results
so I created a Google spreadsheet I'd
like a verage doubt like six rounds or
whatever but I also had to make the
fourth bottle following the instructions
that the dad had provided and Jesse had
to make this was making the simple syrup
by boiling the the water with the sugar
basically what happened was is trying to
make the first time we made this bottle
tornado machine I didn't get it quite
together didn't get it quite together
and the very first time that Shepherd
begins to do the thing to get the
tornado going the whole thing comes
apart in sugar water goes all over the
kitchen okay that's called a failed
experiment so and I did not do well with
that I did not respond well and the next
thing that happened was we got it back
together and then as we're getting ready
to seal it scheppers like playing around
with another one knocks it over and then
sugar water goes all over the ground
again and I'd I'm not proud of how I
yelled at that moment oh we finally get
was it like Eureka yeah it was a Mont
yeah exactly
and so then we finally get it together
but the sugar water is so hot that for
some reason it's like it's not cooling
down and so I'm like we're gonna have to
put it in here and wait till the morning
and then we'll do the experiments in the
morning but because I put hot sugar
water in there and when it cooled we
wake up and like the top bottle is like
compressed in like oh wow
so no tornadoes could be made and so I
was like we got to do this again and
Jesse was like let's just say the
results of the sugar water were
inconclusive it's third grade right so
I've got great stats for the first three
bottles again with the line all right
the McLaughlin family is no well
actually we what's just fun
the results yeah we know we conferred
with it with the other the other dad and
I was like I feel like we need to do
this again he was like I don't worry
about it we've got three there's still
an experiment they've learned whatever
who cares they've learned they're not to
get certain dad's involved in the
tornado but I just you know I just wish
I had more patience I just I it when I
get into evolved in those situations and
I have to start contributing to it in a
meaningful way I just
and then things start falling apart I
just I'm not good at just patiently just
getting my way through that it's really
tough to work on something that's not
something that you're you're personally
passionate I'm personally passionate
about water tornadoes no once they go
like I'm that way too I mean it's like
we're so spoiled I think it because so
much of what we do is our creative
vision and to step into our kids world
and to parent them is a selfless act and
I mean when you don't experience having
a like having a boss employer
relationship that often and we really
don't I think that ironically between us
and our kids we're the spoiled ones
especially in that sense and I think
it's yeah it's harder to it you know we
we've trained ourselves to be so engaged
in what it is we want to do that I feel
like as a parent I'm constantly fighting
this instinct of being spoiled with with
my own prerogatives well I spent I spend
the majority of my and Chrissy and I
talk about this because you know she she
spends a lot of time with our kids and a
lot more than I do and I feel for you
know it's like it's it's so tough being
a great parent because I'm having a
tough time just being an average one and
but it so the way that I deal with that
is at least with honesty they're like I
try to be honest I'd you know I try to
apologize or just be real with the with
the kids I'm not answering a question
anymore
in sign up before we move on to another
question do I have a zit bandaid on my
face oh yeah you do but I'm sure they
can't see it what because I meant to
take that off don't take it off no no no
now you're committed just you see it
right there
yeah but there's no way you can see that
in the dim lighting man you shouldn't
even mention it I know but I there was a
moment maybe you saw it when I had the
link face in the middle of your talking
about the tornado thinking about your
illness I realized that I had is it
because on a put a I have a zit there
and she puts she put a thing oh I love
those things she and it is it heals up
underneath it I've warned them to many
different into public events really like
yeah cuz you don't you forgot that
they're there no she puts it on and I'm
like I gotta go dude I gotta go do this
thing nothing like special and I'm
nothing like public appearances okay
Tiffany McGowan's got a question
fire away Tiffany so I'm 26 and while I
love children I firmly know that I don't
want to be a parent pretty much everyone
in my life thinks I'm just young and
I'll change my mind when I meet the
right guy my question is did you always
know you wanted to be parents or did
meeting your wives actually change your
minds also how can I get everyone to
back off on the whole having kids
business everybody you know it's
everybody doesn't need to have kids
everybody everybody shouldn't have kids
that that's first of all that's the easy
thing we talked about this a little bit
right it's it's it's it's our
prerogative we talked about this a
little bit in a previous podcast where
so you can go but I don't know what
schepis thought it was but we had
friends who were asking us so we want to
hear our perspective on that you can go
listen but but I do think that the this
is an interesting question because based
on where we grew up in kind of the
culture that we were in specifically I I
think that it never ever crossed our
minds that we would not be fathers it
was just if you weren't a father it was
I'm wrong with you you know you you were
supposed to do two things you're
supposed to get marry three you're
supposed to get a job you when you
graduate from college because you know
you started we started thing about that
stuff when we were in college right you
get a job yeah you get a job you get a
job right after
you graduate you get a life partner and
get married you do that as quickly as
possible
basically yeah and then relatively
quickly
maybe yeah maybe a few years maybe a few
years of kids lessness but then you got
to start having children and again
neither of us have any regrets because
what else are you gonna do right we
don't have any any regrets about that
but I think that you know having 20
almost 20 years passing since we got
married
kind of looking back on it you're like
oh it was just that was the cultural
expectation of where we were who we were
at the time and and I you know the
negotiation wasn't if we're gonna have
kids
it was the conversations were women
exactly you know wait we were three
years into marriage when we started
trying right that seems really early to
me but you changed so much over you know
18 years of marriage anyway it's like I
mean that does introduce the next a next
phase yeah if you don't have kids and
then you get married well then it that's
certainly introducing kids at that point
it really changes it changes the dynamic
for everybody along with many other
things that happen in life but from for
us because it's a I mean it seems like
such a huge decision it really well it
is okay because it changes your entire
life the decision became easier for us
because we were friends with other
families who had kids like we would
Christy would babies in our first few
years of marriage she would babysit for
other people's kids like they would hang
out with us a little bit so you start to
see okay these little people here
sometimes babies sometimes grade school
kids you know we started to see like the
okay look at these families they're
making it work we're getting to know
these families they're good friends of
ours they have not just babies but kids
in grade school middle school even
wow this is something that it's really
working for them and you see it up close
and personal and but you never present I
know I know I think we I think we did
I do remember Christian I talking about
it as if you wouldn't have this the
other option was not having children no
it was just growing comfortable with the
ice starting to starting to try to have
kids ourselves because even though it
was a foregone conclusion we were gonna
do it it was still a very daunting
decision said okay we're actually going
through with this yeah I should try to
make a baby
and so that I do remember that making us
feel much more comfortable in like being
up close and personal with like parents
and kids that loved each other and that
it was working I mean because I came
from a broken home you know it was a
scary thing for me because I you know I
always felt like what I didn't do it
right I subconsciously I was just you
know it was just I had a stepdad and
then at third grade it was just me and
my mom from there on out and it was like
well we didn't do it right it was okay
it was great even my my childhood was
great but I didn't want to I mean it had
its challenges because of that you had
more trepidation yeah because because I
I didn't know if there was something
about like some say something in my
genes that I was gonna I was gonna
repeat that cycle something your genes
is what causes the whole problem
je aja
yes okay because I think that I'm not
currently the way genes the way that
I've always approached these kinds of
things is like you know there are a lot
of people who are fearful about things
like I'm afraid to drive a car like if
you might be about to get your license
or I'm afraid to fly on a plane because
I've never done that before yeah I'm
afraid to have a child and I think the
way I've always processed those things
is like well I'm afraid to like climb a
mountain right because that's something
that a very small percentage of the
population does I'm afraid to swim with
a shark give somebody a trach on the
spot because there's very few people who
can do that
right yeah but there's millions of
people who've been parents there's
millions billions of people who've been
parents and so I kind of go into those
situations that everyone I'm just like
statistically it can't be I mean I'm not
ready for this but who is let's just do
it I think that's how I've approached
and that's I think I approached kids
that way and honestly I kind of think
that that was my experience once we had
kids it was like this is really
difficult and hard but this is exactly
what everyone said it was going to be
everyone was like it's the greatest
thing and the most difficult thing
you'll ever go through and it's like
okay that and you know what turns out
that's true
and so but I think that answer Tiffany's
question uh you know is it okay I mean
so we answered your question did you not
know we never considered it but I think
that it's totally okay if especially if
you're like I know I don't want to be a
parent well this is not the kind of
thing you should be talked into a forced
into or pressured into trust me and then
how do you get everyone to back off on
the whole having kids business I don't
know that I don't know that the dynamic
of where you're at but it sounds like
everyone is expecting you to do it so
you might just have to firmly just tell
people to stop it stop talking about
that
quit asking me about that I'll let you
know I'll tell you when I'm pregnant
probably never I think a lot of people
like the parents grandparents situation
they you know they think that it's an
innocuous ribbing but I think if you
just have a moment of hey I just want to
I just want to let you know for a second
that it it it does it does start to hurt
and I know you don't mean it
maybe if you level with them that will
help mm-hmm good luck with that
Samantha asks me and most of our answers
with good luck with that like all great
gonna move on like all great advice
givers what are you good luck with that
Dear Abby had a lot of success with
ending all her
bosses like that Samantha de asks why do
different siblings get different
treatment as the oldest I felt as though
my parents were very strict but were way
more laid back with my other younger
siblings was I just the guinea pig of
three children yes yes definitely I mean
I'm an only child you're you're the
youngest of two so I don't I don't have
too much to go on from my childhood
experience but as a parent yeah you just
you're your will to impose your will on
another person it just degrades over
time I mean it's like I can't imagine
being a king you know it's like it's
just tough to try to get people to do
what you want them to do I mean that's
not and that's the trap of parenting
right it's like when you when you go on
autopilot it's just I don't want to hear
you talking now so I'm gonna turn off
the volume you know I cuz I'm you're so
you're surviving right but but but
shifting to I'm trying to foster a
growing budding human being to be an
independent positive force on planet
Earth that is not under my control much
less is not there for my happiness and
my comfort well I think this is just
this is human nature it's true and I
would say it's true in almost every
family and it just makes sense right so
if I'm moving fragile sculptures into a
home I'm gonna be more careful with the
first one because I don't know I just
don't know the dynamics of the situation
right it's like the first time you do
something there's all these
considerations you're learning all these
lessons and you're being overprotective
and then the second sculpture you bring
in isn't like I actually transport
fragile sculptures into my home all the
time now I don't even have a fragile
sculpture in my home but you can imagine
that the second thing you do you are you
you you take a few more risks in fact
while you grow comfortable with a level
of risk that's reasonable
I think and you all and I think you also
hold this with two hands but I'm not
gonna put it in a satchel inside of my
t-shirt and then maybe on the fourth
trip you've got three sculptures you've
got one in each hand and 104 I'm
wondering each arm you know I'm saying
like you're like this is this is good
and one of these breaks I've already got
two in the house but subconsciously that
that is true though I don't think it I
don't think you love you don't value
them any less unless the third sculpture
is not any less valuable to you but
there's this there's a certain
reasonable amount of effort that you
don't an unreasonable amount of effort
that's not worth expending based on
experience yeah it's just not you learn
what's worth it was not worth it I I
wonder if it ever goes the opposite
direction I mean certainly if there's if
there's if a tragedy but Falls a family
I mean that goes without saying even
though I just said it but like in a
normal situation of of health and
hashtag blessing I didn't I don't think
it ever goes the other way it's like you
you're strict but if something if
something if you go through something
then you're gonna you're going to
tighten the reins with with a subsequent
channel but but in my case here's what I
tell I mean
Lily and Lincoln gets so frustrated with
Lando because he's he's still at an age
where he he can't express his
frustration logically sometimes so it
just comes out in like tattling or a
form of tantrum but it's also it's not
he is you know he is a special
personality compared to your other kids
oh yeah same way that Shepard is very
different from life oh yeah they're all
I don't think it all different but it's
just an age they know I know I'm not
what I was getting at what I was getting
at was because he's he's the youngest I
find myself saying to Lily and Lincoln
yes I I think
Lando is wrong here Lando needs to have
more self-control Lando the right thing
to do in this instance is something
different but what he's doing is
annoying the crap out of you and me but
there's only so much I can do
yes he's in his room right now and he's
screaming and throwing a
trip but what I'm asking for you is even
though you may have been more in the
right
you're also older and you've got to do
something to make peace I can make this
argument all the time
you gotta you've you with more age comes
more responsibility and just let's just
hold this together let's plug the let's
plug the gaps in this in the ship it
doesn't always work though it and that's
frustrating that's frustrating fourth
you know a 13 year old 15 year old or a
39 year old the thing in that lock
points out specifically he points this
out all the time he says dad you would
never have let me do that you would
never have let me watch that you oh you
would have never let me be on screens
that much or you know and it's true
right oh yeah and so but the funny thing
is is just the other day this is
actually this is another story from our
trip and Palm Springs others like you're
gonna say another lie we were sitting
there the three of us Jesse was shopping
and we were waiting to get into a
restaurant we were I had a little buzzy
thing that was gonna ring and we're
gonna go to this restaurant and we were
sitting at this table together outside
quality time and with dad I'm I I gotta
say I was on my phone at the time
checking something important you know
probably related to either at read emcee
on Twitter or at read emcee on Instagram
shout-out to both you know just keep it
up with the social media streams and not
father my children and so my kids are
talking to each other and you know if I
just wanted to let if it if it defeats
them to a fraction of the level that it
defeats me every time you bring it up I
don't shout out I don't shout out my
Twitter and my Instagram in front of my
children I just go passers-by I just
ignore my children and go on social
media in time to time now but what I was
doing was not currently engaging in
fatherhood and my kids were talking to
each other and Shepard was saying a
series of things to lock that were just
they get into these fights and they're
both boys and they were completely
joking with each other but Shepard was
things things like I'm gonna
kill you I'm gonna bite your face off
I'm gonna put your head into a blender
like like a series of things and it was
just like you know you this is I mean
you may think that's crazy
but I'm gonna torture mutilate you in
these very specific ways and he said
what's your return he said this series
of things and I didn't hear any of them
and then like says Shepard I'm gonna
kill you know I was like look don't talk
to your brother like that and he was
like dad that was a test
we were testing you because I knew you
wouldn't say anything when Shepard said
all that and as soon as I said something
you would say luck and you did it
haha and I was like I'm sorry man I was
like I guess it's mind if I tweeted
about it and I told him I said I did not
hear I honestly did nothing that Shepard
said could ever imply here it just went
I didn't hear it at all I didn't process
it but when you said that and so he was
making the point that you have a
different standard for me and I was like
you're right I do and that's wrong and I
will continue to work on that but you
could said well at least I hear you I
don't hear the younger one so they
weren't even serious well you know it's
but it just it's kind that's kind of
related it's just you do approach things
differently with the second child and
I'm sure it screws them up a little bit
it screws up the older kid and it screws
up the younger kid but you know what
they just get older and they say things
like I'm a younger child I just tell
people that like when they'll go on
dates and everything's all right that's
my theory good luck with that
[Music]
amber h asks i have three boys who are
similar in age to your kids eleven
fourteen and fifteen and a half okay I
constantly think about their future and
how I will have to adjust to life
without them at home as much as I worry
about whether they are going to be ready
to go off to college and do it on their
own my husband doesn't seem to give it a
second thought and is just enjoying the
time with him now don't get me wrong I
do enjoy them now too but differently
than he does how are the two of you
coping with your kids growing up and how
do you think it differs from the way it
affects your wives hmm well I think I
just demonstrated it a second ago I
don't want to generalize between what
you're about
like moms and dads but I mean from my
experience III i will say that we
definitely share your experience in our
house that Christy I mean she seems to
have this like instinctual connection
with the worst case scenario now that
that's part of her personality profile
in general so I don't think it's all
about being a mom but she because she
has like that that gift to like see the
worst future and therefore and thereby
avoid it to the benefit of our entire
family right but it does but maybe
there's a mom component to it too that
me is it makes me feel it will make me
feel better if I knew that biologically
there was a mom thing that as a dad I
just I just can't I just not capable of
worrying about on that much but I do
find that to be true just in practice
that like you know she's thinking you
know I could decide to think about the
future now so I am curious for you
because you're more of a your very
future minded and I'm very like not that
so between me and Christy it's like she
does question like that's like don't
don't question whether I love the kids
just because I don't worry about them
nearly as much as you do because I
believe that I do but how do you think
that is for you I mean what's the
dynamic with you and Jesse well I mean
this is a complex question yeah and I'm
not interested in digging any holes for
us by saying the wrong thing because you
do get in trouble when you start making
generalizations about men and women and
how they relate to kids you're right and
there are exceptions to everything I do
think that there are some very
significant cultural components that
contributed to the way that we see our
role as fathers and our wives see their
role as mothers yeah that contributed to
kind of the way that we've gone about
our family business I also think there's
probably some biological factors that
are that are real and I think that I'm
not an expert on that and
I'm not trying to you know come to any
conclusions about that but what I will
say is that in our two families I think
both our wives tend to be more anxious
about things related to the kids mm-hmm
and so if you look at especially I don't
think this is as common as it was say
you know 5 years ago 10 years ago with
our wives but if you were to just look
at my wife's bedside table and all the
books that she's reading yeah you know
nine out of ten ten years ago nine out
of ten of those books would have been
solely related to child rearing and
parenting parenting and everything
related to their kids and I you know I
probably read half of one book about
parenting me too and I think some of it
can be related to you know me and you
probably have a tendency to just be like
we'll figure it out as we go
what does that book really gonna teach
us or whatever but at the same time I
was reading books about a lot of other
things so I think part of it was just
pure selfishness of just wanting to be
into the things that I was into and also
and a comfort level that she was taking
care of it and we would certainly talk
about it because our primary job that
was to go and be in turn attainers well
in our in our wives primary job yeah has
been to raise our kids which is not the
kids because of that we were doing the
homeschool kit for years so it was it
was literally that was their I their
occupation right up until em a year and
a half ago right so whenever I would say
things like well you know what we're
doing the right things and you're doing
an amazing job don't don't worry I'm
trying to reassure her it's like what
yet but and if something if there's
something an indication that's something
they didn't make a right decision or
they don't know something that maybe
there's an indication they should have
known or made another decision it's like
well it was hard for Christine not to
take that personally because it was she
was their teacher she was your primary
teacher yeah you know so it was an
extremely challenging position to be in
well and I would say that
for them in even if and even if there
are significant biological factors that
contribute to this different perspective
that doesn't excuse our behavior that
way that we did it you know because I
mean first of all you know we have a
tendency to want to eat very sugary
fatty things because many many years ago
and we didn't have processed foods if
you found something that had a lot of
fat I had a lot of sugar you had all
that you had every an incentive-based to
eat it based you know based on survival
so just because something is it has a
biological component doesn't mean that
it should dictate your behavior it can
be something to overcome which I think
that because because you know one of the
things we talked about this with our
wives quite a bit like they made some
big sacrifices you know they both got
college degrees and then put the bulk of
their 20s and 30s into teaching our
children and it was incredibly it's been
incredible for our family
but they had to put like we get that we
get to come in here and you know do all
the stuff that we do and have all the
fun that we do and pursue these dreams
while they're doing that and I think at
one point it may have been referred to
in a heated argument as the mythical
castle you get to go to your mythical
constant called it the castle she did
yeah Wow I get to go off to your mid
never can never said that to me your
wife or my life and you know what she
was making a good point yeah you know
I've already alluded to this at the
beginning of the podcast how spoiled we
are but I'd you know the good news is is
even just in the before first of all one
of the cool things that's happening with
the kids being as cool is that our wives
are now able to ask those questions and
have that time and it is McGinn to
figure out how they're gonna be
investing their time in their dreams it
is going to impact us in the amount of
time that we have to worry about the
kids now well hopefully not okay but but
I mean but we did kind of dodged a
bullet in a sense because our kids are
gonna be it won't be long and our kids
are gonna be out of the house it's gonna
be like
and they're gonna be they're gonna be
out of the house but I think that it
that this is a question that especially
if you are I mean and for amber she's
got kids that are about our age so she's
kind of in the same boat it's like well
in a lot of ways that that dynamics
probably not gonna change significantly
but I think that if you're you're young
you're just getting married in if you're
thinking about having kids I do think
that if I could go back I would think
about these things differently and not
just fall into this well I'm gonna just
go do this I think I could have been
more considerate and more involved and
more attentive to these things even if
even if nothing changed about the
dynamics of how much time I was going to
be there I think I did say look at all
these books she's doing all this
thinking about this well I I I'm just
gonna support her by continuing to go
over here and make money I think there's
a better way to do that which is yeah
let's go over here and make money for
the family but let's also find ways to
be personally involved in this in this
process - I can read another book it's
not that hard to do you know well and we
may be projecting a little bit of our
both of our experiences on amber
situation which was it could be
different just because he doesn't worry
as much as she does again that worry is
a big component of personality so I
think it's less of I mean if you have
the gift of not being burdened with
worrying about a certain thing that
that's a totally different variable than
how much do you love it you know if you
got to look at like an investment of
time an investment of energy and right
you know thought effort it's a different
thing and yeah you know so I think
ultimately what we're saying amber is
good luck with that
Liz akkem what was the best trip your
parents took you on as a kid and do you
want to take your kids back to that
place my parents took me and my sisters
to museums all the time and I'm glad for
it I would definitely take my kids to
museums all the time if my husband and I
had kids I didn't get I didn't I didn't
go to a lot of places
as a kid I remember that my mom took
well when when when she and Jimmy were
still married we went we went to Disney
World when I was very young I don't
remember it I was like four and I just
there's pictures of me crying but when I
was older we went to Busch Gardens and
we have pictures of that pictures you
crying there are you happy there honey I
was kind of happy kind of kind of happy
but then I remember later mom took me
and you to Kings Dominion mm-hmm
yeah we have picture there's a picture
of us standing in front of her car in
the book of mythicality that was where
that in front of the hotel we stayed at
yeah on the car
yeah we're leaning against the car cool
guys cool guys what I think of when I
think about those guys cool guys
short shorts long socks haven't go
haven't taken my kids back to Kings
Dominion but we have been to like
Disneyland this is a great question
because I've never thought about this
before but I tend to think of my
childhood as a series of tentpole events
right yank that you typically you have
very specific memories about the
environment that you were in most so you
can kind of picture your childhood home
but when you think about your parents
and the experiences with them at least
for me personally a lot of times it's
things like I remember my dad taking me
and my brother to Raven Rock you know
west of Lillington North Carolina
there's a state park Raven Rock State
Park that the Cape Fear goes through the
Cape Fear River is a huge rock that the
Native Americans would they would camp
underneath the ledge yeah it's it it's
under feet it's super cool and I
recently thought to myself I wonder how
many times we actually went there I bet
you we went there so fewer times that I
actually think because it stands so big
in my memory as something that we would
do
I also remember even earlier than that
when we lived in Thousand Oaks
California not too far from here
my dad would take his can't hiking on
tarantula Hill oh I remember this
tarantula he'll never saw tarantula
there don't know why what's called that
and it really was just a hill it was
just a big mound of you know earth that
you kind of walked up and it was it
definitely wasn't a mile of just kind of
walking around and getting to the top
and coming back down it's funny and I
can have just a buttload of those kinds
of memories that are very much like
taking me out of my normal environment
taking me to a place in doing something
with me
some of it was vacations going to the
beach or going to the Grand Canyon
whatever but I feel like that's what
kind of makes a child's memories so the
way that I've sort of processed that and
applied it to my kids is I've tried to
do that like I try to do these trips you
know we try to take our kids places we
try to travel with our kids like Locke
got to go to Africa with Jessie last
year I did I wasn't able to go but like
that's something he'll never forget that
because it was so outside of the box of
normal life
sure but specifically an answer to this
question I drove to Thousand Oaks less
than a year ago with Jesse and Shepherd
Lockwood know what it was is we dropped
lock off at a basketball camp out there
and then I was like let's go by the old
house the old house I grew up in if you
if you watched our videos for a long
time you know that Lincoln I actually
went to my old house one time and
Thousand Oaks and the man did not want
to speak with us but we went by the old
house but the neighbor did in the Nate
your neighbor was still there yeah and
this time I did not speak to the
neighbor or the current resident but I
was like I did some things like how far
we were we from school because we used
to walk to school and I was like five
years old and like I'd walk with my
brother ganya
it was a one mile from from the square's
field school you know and then I was
like Oh tarantula Hill I remember
tarantula Hill this place so we it was
like a mile away from the house and we
went there and we didn't get out and
walk around I wasn't that cool of a dad
because we needed to be somewhere but I
just like saw this mound of dirt I mean
it's it's more than its it's just a
grassy hill but there's nothing to it
and I was like that meant so much to me
because my dad would just
can we just walk around and then come
back down we're like just doing that
kind of thing that's what that's what my
childhood is you made up if you had
screens back then man ooh you're not
gonna make those kinds of women on the
hill I'm not gonna make those kinds of
memories by being Zelda I'm trying to
tell Shepherd that but it's not having
much of an effect anyway so yes I have
taken the kids to some of those places
but yeah I think that creating those
kinds of experiences because my my
parents did that with me is something
that I've tried to then do with the kids
and you know yeah create the memory
every weekend you try to do something I
mean we last why you got the RV man I'd
like to see a good movie but that's why
I'm like yeah this RV is they're never
gonna get an order to get that RV you
know even if you never do it again then
that RV trip to the Grand Canyon is
going to be this huge tent pole memory
like when they're like what's some of
the stuff you did with your dagger uh
well one time he got this RV we went to
the Grand Canyon I mean he couldn't even
get out of the driveway yeah all right
and we had to build a land but exactly I
mean you make yeah yeah yeah we try to
make decisions I mean I was joking last
week that you know it's great to know
that even and if it goes sideways that
is I can make it entertainment and talk
about it with you guys but I mean I hope
you knew and I was definitely thinking
that's like I was creating this is a
family experience that then added
benefit is it gives us something to talk
about here but I'm a mistake into a
story let's end on the on this on this
doozy of a question mm-hmm Harriett asks
I'm not a parent but this is a question
coming from the lack of discussion on
this topic in my household from my
parents how do you talk to your children
about the birds and the bees what does
that mean well first of all you know my
approach was informed by my experience
as a child and you know when I was 12 or
13 I guess my mom who worked at the
Harnett County Health Department I think
I've told this story before but it
always is worth telling again so that
anyone can learn from it
at the front of the Harnett County
Health Department there were all types
of brochures about all types of health
things that you would need to learn
about every STD you can imagine and so
one day my mom comes home with a
brochure and she handed hands it to me
and she says here's a brochure
I don't know how much you love them I
just want you to I just want you to look
through it and if you have any questions
you know you can ask me anything
I took the brochure now when she said
that did you have any idea what do you
think it was gonna be like a visit
Montana brought like what cut kind of
brochure did you think it was medical
did you know were you familiar with the
brochures in general well the the
picture on the front was very graphic oh
describe it no I'm joking yes sorry I
wanted a middle picture I I don't recall
I do have to imagine knowing myself at
the time that the moment I was handed
the brochure I was just seized with with
fear and awkwardness deep embarrassment
not embarrassment really as much well
maybe and then I was like okay and then
I took it back to my room and then I
walked in my room and then I walked into
my closet I grabbed a flashlight well
we're gonna try that a sat down in the
closet with the door closed with a
flashlight if you're hiding from a home
intruder I'm like I'm like a
twelve-year-old kid I mean it's like
you're in the safe room and I'm like I'm
like reading this thing and like even if
even if somebody comes in they won't see
me the closet and somebody being your
mom yeah I guess yeah even though she
told you to Bree the brochure what are
you doing in there I'm reading the
brochure you just asked me to I'm sorry
I didn't I'm pretty sure I never had any
follow-up questions for my mom yeah and
she knew that when she gave you the
brochure that you were not going to come
to our question right maybe it's I would
call it more of a pamphlet or even a
booklet I mean how many page it had
Leafs in it how many pages I mean it was
it for someone of your age it was like
this big it was like so what's that
seven inches by five inches yeah don't
start giving seven seven inch
measurements in this context so it
wasn't like a tourism brochure visit sex
sex town you strap in oh sorry did you
learn anything
oh yeah so do you think it too late for
me I hadn't already learned
you're not real good with numbers so do
you really think you were twelve
thirteen like is that how old you think
you were and was this new information to
you did I don't let's just all get
imagine that I was eleven okay
and was it all new did you have any idea
about the it'sit'sit's rules involved
and I mean I I had an idea you know but
it was a mission for the specific
mechanics of it what was was it was
eye-opening and it was so it was line
drawing it was sketches yeah well so I
mean I cuz I remember and one of the
differences between me and you is that I
was thinking about these things earlier
than you were oh yeah but I did not have
any clear picture of them literally I
didn't have a picture I didn't get a
brochure from my parents so I was kind
of but you had an older brother yeah and
that see I think that's he with a cliche
he didn't we didn't talk about it I
think we were maybe a little too close
in a I don't know three years apart I
don't know exactly why but he didn't
talk to me about it it was more picking
things up from other kids our age but
you were interested you were like
looking for clues oh yeah
and I was sleuthing I remember piecing
things together in middle school and
kind of putting it all together and
understanding exactly what was involved
but it was more of a just you know
occasional casual reconnaissance mission
just gathering you know Intel from
different people and putting it together
but I did not and it could be wrong
about this but I do not remember how
a specific there may have been like a
very early talk at some point before I
was really processing and understanding
all the things involved for my parents
but I do not remember that and also
think it was very much a generational
thing I everybody I know who's our age
when I asked them did you get a talk
from your parents it's either yes it was
very brief and or no I didn't get one it
was it but it wasn't this like over
before I knew it much like the accuracy
it was it was some it was passive in
some manner like here's a brochure go in
the closet and read it and again I don't
blame who knows what we're doing the
screw at the next generation up right
now
but that was kind of what our parents
did he just didn't talk about those
things typically but you didn't you know
but you don't recall a any sort of
pamphlet no words we didn't really
believe in pamphlets in general in my
family but you but never saw one in the
house but so you don't recall the talk
either though no I do not and have you
asked him about it like do they recall
it because I understand it now I don't
but I don't I don't go to my parents day
to get this kind of information now you
didn't even know we haven't asked leave
we've never talked about it
hey mom tell me about the time you tell
me about sex cuz I can't remember it
yeah that's how I bring that but let's
talk about how we have then well you
were about to explain I'll just say how
you've done it based on your expected
just I've always made it a point because
to counteract my experience with my mom
that like we didn't we didn't talk
through a lot of things I mean it's just
it's just that's just how it was I
wanted to do something different I
wanted to be more open and have more
honest conversations and from an earlier
age and so you know there's also
generational there wouldn't be an
instinctive I just didn't want to give
my kids an instinctive an instinct when
they got some sort of information like I
did that they had to go hide because I
don't
that just doesn't strike me as a healthy
response a healthy way to view sex is
that it's something that's it's
clandestine you know or automatically
dirty or something to be ashamed of or
something to be secretive about I mean
it's in the proper with a proper
understanding I mean it's it's it's
totally normal I mean it's and it's
important yeah and and it's important to
gain a proper understanding of sex in
the in in the context of conversations
with people that you trust and that you
love and that it can be a safe place to
understand you know over time because
it's not just one talk yeah and I don't
think that it's just a you know I think
a lot of people may put this off on you
know a teacher or professional this
teaching sex ed or whatever and that's
fine and potentially great and I do
think that sex education at school is
something I believe in I think is
important because not all parents are
going to do this but it's extremely
difficult to do but I think that at
least in the circles that we run in now
and again I think this is slightly
cultural but also generational it's like
we don't have there's nobody that we
hang out with who has kids who hasn't
had that it's like we talk to other
parents about the talk like we've all
talked about the talk that we had right
we clear notes when did you talk about
it what did you say right and I also
think it depends on the kid because I'm
not gonna name my kids names at this
point cuz you know I've only got two
so don't I'm not trying to embarrass him
so but one of my kids was much more
inquisitive about it was asking a lot of
very pointed questions about the process
and not accepting Pat answers that tried
to oversimplify things you've got Pat
involved nope no Pat was uninvolved you
can't pay a person named Pat to come in
and there's one sex talk but that is not
what I did and then my and my other kid
was not so inquisitive and asking me all
these questions
but for the kid who was asking the
questions I sat down and had a talk
where I explained everything basically
everything in very technical details and
continued to confirm I was almost like
when you were explained this stuff about
the RV I was like got it I kept saying
got it and then I would ask questions to
make sure that he understood and it's
really I think a good practice is the
thing that I did was you want to you
want to see what where their minds are
with their follow-up questions so that
you can answer those as opposed to just
given an information dump and
overwhelming them and then it's like it
may be too much too soon yeah
so it's more again it's it's the
beginning of a conversation it's it's
multiple conversations and it comes in
installments and it still happens right
so I think that's the other thing is
that and again kids get to a certain age
when they start when when it becomes
real so like it's before they go through
puberty kids this is all very
theoretical but as they begin to go
through puberty and as they pass through
puberty it becomes very real to them and
they're like oh all the stuff all that
stuff that dad mom told me is now I can
I understand it because it's happening
to me in my body and that mean that's a
good point
is that you're talking about those
things too you're talking about puberty
you're talking about your body changing
you're having a lot of potentially
awkward conversations and it's not just
all about sex well bring production
exactly what I'm saying is that once it
becomes personal to them
most kids then have a tendency to
withdraw a little bit and be like I
think this conversation needs to stop
because this is not this is no longer
theoretical this is personal mm-hmm and
so I think at that point you kind of
have to keep going back there and it to
be
I mean sometimes and this doesn't happen
to do this isn't just limited to talking
about sex it could be anything that's
potentially uncomfortable or not cool to
talk to your parents about I just say
listen we're that's not gonna be a
dynamic in our family I'm not good
you're not gonna be too cool or too
awkward to talk to me about that I've
only got you for a few
and we're going to talk about anything
and everything and we're gonna break
right through the awkwardness III have
to say that sometimes so then we could
then have the conversation but as much
as from earlier you know I like to fib a
little bit when it comes to this stuff I
don't I don't I don't joke around I mean
I joke around I make jokes but I don't
all the information that I give is
intended to be as helpful and it's true
as possible but it is I mean but that
first conversation what's so funny that
I recorded the entire thing I have the I
know that you did that but even when you
tell it to me again I still feel a wave
of shock come over that you bugged your
sex talk it was actually what happened
is I I like said one thing cuz you know
where you're supposed to do his response
was so funny
I gotta record this what do you say you
pulled your phone I pulled out the the
memo recorder the voice recorder on the
iPhone and I just turned it on and and
then proceeded to have the talk and but
did you say this conversation is being
recorded for quality assurance purpose I
think at one point said dad are you
recording this
and I was like yeah maybe you know don't
worry about it well played at your
rehearsal dinner you know that kind of
thing
do you where do you have it now well you
know I already released it as an album
have you saved it
yeah I gotta sure you got it saying the
voice in voice memos are you gonna play
it at the rehearsal dinner right now
I'm gonna play it for him again and be
like hey if you want me to edit this
thing into something funny and we'll
play it at your rehearsal dinner I mean
cuz I got it
I think it'd be hilarious I think it'll
be like the best wedding ever might
played at the ceremony again but it will
all be with permission I'm gonna I mean
I know a channel you could upload it to
and I wouldn't be opposed to it being
there what with a pre-roll ad a channel
this channel like a YouTube change with
a pre-roll ad yeah that's not gonna roll
that so any times I mean it I mean I'm
sure people why did you do that well
it's I
it's private no one no one has ever
listened to in fact I've never listened
back to it it's just I have it okay but
yeah it's it it's something that we
continue to talk about and it is
interesting it's almost uh this is a
reminder to me that like you kind of
have to have a discipline to continue to
talk about it I mean but because like
you said there's a tendency to withdraw
at a certain age and it's in it's our
role to community to say hey this is
this is a this is an important and
normal conversation I mean the first
conversation that that we had it was a
it was a general one with the two older
kids so like Lincoln was younger and it
was just like it was like I don't know
if he's a little too young but we're
having a very general version of the
conversation so we didn't get into this
and that many specifics right just kind
of break the ice about it and it was but
it but it ended up being a you know
trying to find the right words and you
know keep your face in a way that it
seems like hey this is a normal
conversation this isn't I died look this
is what my face looks like when we're
talking about anything at the dinner
table because we were at the dinner
table this is not my sex face yeah or my
sex
this is not my sex talk face and
definitely that's my sex discussion
clarified and so we have this you know
we were like Chrissy and I we were we
were talking about it and we were like
trying trying to keep our cool and
trying to be matter-of-fact about it in
order to send the right signals that hey
this isn't this is normal or whatever
and we did a great job I felt really
good about it and but there wasn't much
reciprocation retort or engagement so
the first the first follow-up and again
I won't say who it was it was
just like there was like a moment of
silence it was like okay was gonna let
you process and then it was the first
thing that was said was awkward but
that's great and you know what that's
fine and I said ocol eyes are a little
awkward and you know I think that's fine
but think about if you hadn't have said
it right in the awkwardness that could
result from it again and I might listen
I don't know if we're doing a good job
at it it's but the because there are
certain things that begin to happen at
certain ages and like I mean the way you
interact with your kid like the way you
show affection to your kid changes like
the way I show affection to Shepherd is
different than the way I show affection
to Locke because it's a nine year old
and a 14 year old you know what I'm
saying yeah and I remember that with my
parents like at some point it was like I
don't kid like I remembered like four or
five years old I was like I go I would
go up to like my mom my dad and then my
grandma and I kiss everybody on the lips
before I went to bed I think that's kind
of a southern thing to do that
yeah it's like like everybody on the
lips and and then at some point well at
some point that you should probably stop
doing that right and I did yeah but it's
funny because there once something stops
it's really difficult to get it back so
hmm
once you no longer say a certain thing
or once you no longer you once you no
longer say I love you which we still say
I love you quite a bit in my family but
you know you might stop saying that at
some point and it's very difficult to
get it back and if you once you quit
talking about sex it's very difficult to
start talking about sex again and then
you're just kind of like um maybe it'll
just work itself out I don't figure it
out they got friends trust me they're
friends have no clue well you do have a
as humans we do have a way of figuring
it out it does kind of yep you know you
don't have to be told but a kid that can
they could it could lead to negative
repercussions to come with certain
consequence
and there's no guarantee that our kids
your kids won't will escape those
consequences regardless of how much you
talk about it mm-hmm
I was remarkably lucky even though I
didn't have a candid conversation with
my parents so all that to say to Harriet
yeah we're trying to talk about it very
intentionally and not have it just be
one conversation but have it be an
ongoing conversation and we'll report
back which which brings us to next
week's conversation when we talk at you
again it will be exclusively about how
babies are made
yeah well have most of our sex faces on
the whole time and I will and I will
bring I will bring my pamphlet you still
got it problem you know I have it on me
and some oh yeah just but you never know
when you read it for reference just you
know what which what's step one is I get
confused what is step one
next week Rhett I'll let you know what's
step one so you can count on us to be
here thanks for listening
always we value a hashtag ear biscuits
feedback and conversation as well as an
iTunes review I mean who are we kidding
here yeah do that too if you're I would
love to see you do that
yeah send us pictures of you doing that
good luck with that
[Music]